joining us now dr ashish jaw he's a dean
of brown university's school of public
health dr john good morning to you
let's start with the facts thank you for
having me i'm so glad you're here
let's start again with the facts because
when i hear people say
i didn't take this seriously i didn't
think that this was something that was
that i really needed to be worried about
what more can you say and i think people
are getting very frustrated because
they're they don't want to feel that
it's being jammed down their throats
what can we say yeah gail i completely
understand
and i have a lot of sympathy for people
who have not gotten vaccinated because
they do
they have just been i do and i'll tell
you why
they have just been fed this non-stop
diet of misinformation about these
vaccines that somehow it was rushed that
somehow it's dangerous
and the people who are spreading that
misinformation they're usually
they usually have an alter agenda on all
of this so what we need to do is we need
to give people facts and the facts are
these vaccines are exceedingly safe and
effective
they work at saving lives and right now
we're only really seeing the
unvaccinated get really sick and die
from this
if you don't want to get sick and die
there's one way out of this get
vaccinated
you know but those of us who have gotten
the vaccine we're thinking it's our
superpower we're protected but now the
unvaccinated people it seems
are now affecting the vaccinated people
do we need to revise everything
when it comes to mask for both
vaccinated and unvaccinated people
wearing the mask yeah it's a it's a
really good question gail i mean at this
point
if you're fully vaccinated you're really
safe from anything serious you might get
a breakthrough infection you might
have a couple of days of not feeling
great but you're not going to end up in
the hospital you're not going to end up
dying
that's the most important thing in terms
of mask wearing it can help on for the
short run
but in the long run kale there's only
one way out of this if we want to put
the pandemic behind us
a lot more americans have to get
vaccinated yeah dr fauci said
just yesterday on tv that we're heading
in the wrong direction
in the spring you were very optimistic
about us heading in the right direction
how are you feeling i would imagine
you're feeling the same
uh you know i am i i was saying in the
spring that we were gonna have a
fabulous summer
through june it looked really good i did
not expect that we'd have a third of
americans refusing to get vaccinated i
just didn't see
that coming i thought everybody wanted
to put the pandemic behind us
everybody wanted to move on i figured 90
95
people would get vaccinated and we could
be done with this thing everybody wants
to tip
tippy toe around dr jaw making ordering
that the vaccines be mandatory
where do you stand on that
yeah you know it's it's crazy how we've
turned this into a political issue
you know when i'm in the hospital i have
to have vaccines for the flu and measles
i can't just show up to work
uh with without it without those
vaccines we've got to treat covet in the
same way and we have managed to somehow
politicize this
i think businesses hospitals schools
have to step up and say
we do this for all these other vaccines
we're going to do it for covet too
all right dr jaw we thank you for your
time good to see you